[Music]
[Applause]
bring in rich eisen host of the rich
eisen show on nbc's peacock that follows
us and uh nfl network host let me ask
you the poll question there rich uh more
likely to happen tampa bay goes to the
super bowl or the cowboys make the
playoffs
well i picked tampa to win
the super bowl so i'll go with tampa
making the super bowl um
i like washington i like the football
team or the red wolves or the commanders
or whatever they're going to be
um i like their defense a hell of a lot
i think chase young is a defensive
player year candidate and um
that was my thought going in
obviously seeing what dak looked like
last night and the way that these
receivers were as advertised
um
but um
would give me a little bit of pause but
i think we saw last night what the
buccaneers can be
which is remove your run game make you a
throw team
um and you know and if you can't
stop if if you can throw on them then
brady will just beat you in the end
and um that was pretty much it last
night i mean the buccaneers turned it
over four times and still won the game
so i'll go with the bucks making the
super bowl who do you have playing the
box
i have the chiefs i have the first
repeat super bowl since the 92 93
seasons
and
i see brady winning it back to back and
then we're gonna sit here have a
conversation
does he want to be a 45 year old guy
trying to be the first to do it three
straight times and i think the answer is
going to be yes
i i know collinsworth tweeted out i
didn't have the game broadcast on where
i was but
um i don't know if he said it last night
but he tweeted out that he couldn't tell
any difference between a 24 and a 44
year old brady and
i mean the there was a third down throw
on third and 10 that went off of
godwin's hands with um i think 10
minutes to go or something like that and
and
it was one of the most remarkable throws
you'll see and a 44 year old shouldn't
make that throw certainly when he's been
uh three quarters into a game
it really is amazing dan we'll never see
anything like it again i know we say
that quite a bit in sports and then we
see something like it again and people
who said that about babe ruth aren't
alive to see ohtani right but i i
i mean we've got we saw a 44 year old
last night take the field defending his
seventh super bowl raising his seventh
banner first with a different team
and playing the way that he did last
night top of his game
top of his game that wasn't a single
diminishing return we saw last night
and that's what's interesting when you
look at athletes what do they lose
you know as they get older what do you
lose
explosiveness
you know hitters will talk about maybe
their eyesight's not as good hand-eye
coordination with brady
what is he going to lose
yeah you know he never had this so he's
not losing anything and if your arm is
as strong as it's ever been
why would he
i mean i wouldn't leave
he he got touched twice last night i
mean right if you got a good line you
got good wide receivers you're having
fun
um
i i see
he's going to play
of course and and i think the the
the throw that
showed me
um a lot maybe his most impressive throw
of the night
was the hail mary at the end of the
first half
when anybody who's 44 years old throwing
the ball half the field how many times
have we seen it go straight up the
chimney and then somebody's like
trying to have a
a a leap at it at the 10 yard line i
mean that was a terrific hail mary throw
from a 44 euro he's making all
the throws right now
um obviously the question will be health
and if they do ever get into a game
where the run game will have to suffice
who's it going to be i guess it'll be
four dead but you know um that was
tremendous just as a great i loved the
whole game obviously but just to see um
the bucks come out like that
last night has to give them a lot of um
momentum moving forward obviously i
wonder about the game plan for the
cowboys it's hard to run against tampa
bay yes but if you're the cowboys
don't you feel like hey
it's hard to defend our running game now
you don't you don't have one of your
better offensive linemen i get that but
you still have an offensive line where
dak is going to throw almost 60 times so
you can't go well you didn't have your
offensive line so we're going to throw
more normally you would probably run the
football instead of expose dak prescott
on a surgically repaired ankle against
one of the better defenses in the league
what did you make of dallas's game plan
well i think it was blown up by um vida
veyo
yeah
what a grown man
oh my god i mean he was throwing people
out of the club last night fourth
quarter
and he was
terrific we obviously
pay attention to jpp
and those linebackers who are terrific
and david and white and clearly you know
sue
but vida veya was the defensive star of
last night and then they throw them out
there as a fullback on offense that
would just you saw fournette i'll just
run behind this guy they just bowled him
down the brooklyn side and took care of
business
last night you know and it was
i think the the the way that the cowboys
saw the way it was going now
you i could
pick up what you're putting down which
is that's 21 back there that's zeke back
there that's the guy who
supposedly is your difference maker and
yeah i think the plan should be to give
him 20 touches a game minimum
uh but i think they they go to pollard a
lot too
so i guess you can't forget that he's
part of the run game
but yes the balance needs to be there
otherwise dak
will will have too much on his shoulders
figuratively but last night all that
even with the shoulder supposedly being
um iffy i mean that was great you have
to walk out of that if you're the
cowboys thinking not only does dak look
terrific
but he is worth every penny
of that 40 million a year he played like
the elite quarterback should in that
game last night and
you know there's a lot of ifs and buts
um but that should be i guess the the
silver lining to take away talking to
rich eisen nfl network host and the host
of the rich eisen show on nbc's peacock
it follows this program
uh who looked younger last night
tom brady
or drew brees
oh
gosh can i go off the board and say jack
collins works dan
i mean he's not a choice but
oh man
i'll i'll still go with brady uh i'll
still go with tb12 you know what i
thought i saw the video
this is what brady this is probably what
keeps him young and keeps him going
is brady the number of people
who he has competed against and has been
put in the same sentence with and breeze
in many ways deserves to be in the same
sentence with brady when you're talking
about record books i mean brady last
night joined brees as the only other
quarterback with
a hundred 300 yard passing games and
he's 32 behind breeze now
so
that's my caveat but the number of times
i've seen brees go up to somebody who
he's been in the same sentence with or
is a member of the media and they're all
in a suit and tie because they're with
the media or they're there to be honored
by their team that night and he's still
in his uniform or he goes up to somebody
like dak
last two quarterbacks he consoled on
that field we're patrick mahomes and dak
prescott and he's 44 years old i think
that's what keeps him
going and looking as young
uh than than somebody else but brees did
look young
dan yeah he had a new addition
um were you talking about a rock band or
what are you talking about
what are you talking about i'm trying to
i'm trying to i'm trying to see what
you're trying to say
what are you trying to say he extended
his hairline
so
see now
you can talk about stuff like that you
know what i'm saying like i i don't know
if i have many follicles to stand on
okay
did you ever think about
dionne has told me over and over and
over again to do what he's done
um which is you know restore
and he calls himself the comeback player
of the year every year now
and um he thinks i should do it he keeps
telling me that my wife really wants me
to do it and she doesn't have the heart
to tell me to do it he says that she's
standing on the side is what he told me
one time that she's standing on the side
you know having one
end of the rope trying to double dutch
with me wanting me to get in there is
what he keeps saying
um but i have accused brian erlacker of
um
being a traitor so i don't know if i
could now go ahead and join that club
dan yeah i don't know if i could well
you don't need to
i think i'm you know a fine wine this is
it
or as the phrase that nfl coaches say it
is what it is
and
um
i don't have a crystal ball i don't
think i'm gonna try it you know i mean i
could keep going on with these cliches
but it is what it is let's take a vote
does rich should he entertain getting
new moss uh
no no no
four
four no no moss no no balls no no randy
no there's right here yeah you know
you don't need to
uh okay if i give you if if the chargers
are a stock and the rams are a stock
oh i i'll take oh god wow
um
ah
i'll take the rams because i think
they're gonna win their division i don't
think the chargers will but i do love
the chargers i love brandon staley i
love herbert i love derwin james they've
got playmakers all over the lot dan
um eckler is as the kel the
cowbell uh back would concern me already
he's missed a practice this week
um
but i'll take the rams i i think
stafford
is the the difference maker that i know
that's been the off-season story that's
been pounded
more than pretty much any but it's also
the one that's been around the longest
it was the first move of the year
um i i'm going to i'm really excited to
see what he looks like in the in this
offense
uh with mcvay so i'll just
first blush say the rams on that
what would you say
the rams lack of depth like they're top
heavy
that the talent they have is really top
end
you know the running situation um
concerns me a little bit
i i do love
you know
having those defensive impactful
defensive players there's no other team
that has two players like that
and
but i do worry about in that division
you're going to beat each other up i
mean even arizona is not a pushover and
if you don't have that depth
then i wonder about that i always go
i've gone all in on the chargers many
many times and they always disappoint me
i think staley's going to be a
difference maker i really do um i like
him i like him a lot um he went to
dayton so you should i know that he's a
quarterback at dayton turned defensive
guy and um
i i do believe they've got the right guy
um some of the
things i'm hearing out of the chargers
locker room is they love him they they
have bought what he sold the minute he
showed up and i think that will be some
some difference maker that you'll see in
wins and losses and potentially and i
have to say this potentially is doing a
very heavy lift potentially remove the
bat guano crazy things that happen to
the chargers when there's 10 seconds
left in the clock or less
that always seems to beset this team
yeah um i i think it'll be different but
i'll just still take the rams uh donald
donald up front and derwin uh i mean and
and and jaylen ramsey in the back i i
would take those two over bosa and
derwin james by by a margin i would take
them on that defensive side have a great
weekend i know you got to get up early
on sunday right
oh yes back but uh the wind beneath my
wings on that dan my uh my uh my new
studio that i'm i'm i'm broadcasting
from
uh the nfl network built this beautiful
palace across the street from
sofi and it is amazing the whole place
has got a whole
jolt of energy to it so it's going to be
phenomenal now you're you're revealing
that on sunday because i watched last
night that was it oh
that was it
i couldn't tell the difference no
i mean it looked nice
okay good yeah but
if you would have said here here's some
things to keep an eye on
yes
um
we didn't we didn't use the full
okay well um
we didn't use the full
you know um space okay there's gonna be
we just sat at a desk we didn't show off
the different places where you can
do something from including the you know
how all all the uh pregame shows have
like this five yard piece of turf that
they shoot to make it look like it's 50
you know and you do a demo and it's like
a five wide and they're all like this
going five wide
we actually have about a 20 30 yard
space outside
and the backdrop is so fast
we have not used that yet that's coming
sunday that'll be sunday the big reveal
yes the big there's going to be a whole
big to-do and you're coming on my show
at 12 20 eastern so i look forward to
the home at home but i don't know if
i'll say anything different than i just
said here can you just take my answers
here and no i've i've already taken
copious mental notes about what we've
discussed
we'll cover new ground dan because i'm a
lead pipe building professional like
that i know you are too you'll be able
to handle them it'll be great thank you
really great i look forward to talking
to you in the two hours that's uh
the popular host of the nfl network and
rich eisenhower rich eisen